hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the oneplus one it was a bit of an
unknown phone when it first came out
from a kind of an unknown company since
it's new but when it first came out
about nine months ago i did a video
review on it i've done a revisited video
since then and it seems like every time
i talk about this phone gotta mention
that it will basically live or die by
the software by the fact that it should
hopefully get software updates very
quickly by cyanogen
and for a while it did cyanogen did a
really good job of putting out updates
pretty constantly to fix performance and
to give it new features and to address
things so for a while it did a really
good job in the software update
department so this guy is smoothly
running cyanogenmod 11s for a while
but then it hit a hiccup and cyanogen
made some deals over here and oneplus
said some things over there and
eventually you know without getting into
the details of it oneplus and cyanogen
split so they're no longer working
together so for those of us who own this
phone or were thinking about trying to
buy one
now what well to make a long story short
now oneplus is going to try building
their own rom so it's going to be called
oxygen os they've hired a bunch of very
talented people and they've been working
on it it's going to come out sometime in
march and i'm assuming it's going to be
built on top of android 5.0 lollipop
but in that sort of a mean time where
we're not getting any updates from
cyanogenmod and we're waiting for oxygen
os to be built i got a little bit
impatient so i went ahead and flashed
the latest version of cyanogenmod 12
that is built on lollipop onto my
oneplus one now i actually showed this
to you guys a little earlier some of the
steps i went through on snapchat and
some of you guys actually a lot of you
guys snapped back saying you wanted to
see a video on what this was like so
it's just a quick video on my
impressions of what the experience has
been like on this new os on this not so
new phone so far so it does take a
couple of steps to actually get it set
up obviously it won't come with root
access out the box so i'll leave a link
to the instructions in the oneplus form
that i followed right below that like
button so if you want to follow along to
them it's really really detailed you can
basically get it done with a windows
machine and a usb cable and you're all
set to go uh but yeah without any
further ado let's get into it so there
are a bunch of advantages to using
cyanogenmod which is a custom rom over
just the stock android that you would
find on a nexus 5 or a nexus 6 or
something like that and a lot of those
are basically in customization or things
that you would find that you are able to
change on your phone that you wouldn't
ordinarily be able to change so one of
those things that's i guess most
noteworthy on the oneplus one is the
ability to switch between your on-screen
and off-screen buttons so you can choose
the nav buttons to be on the phone or on
the bottom if you want them on the
screen or off that's your call a lot of
things like that you'll find just buried
in the settings here of cyanogenmod and
these are things that you found in
cyanogenmod 11s and they're going to
continue to move over into 12. you can
also change and add a lot of shortcuts
to things so i have a regular swipe down
from the left just a normal swipe into
your notifications but a swipe down from
the right gets you quickly into your
quick settings and also pretty much all
of these quick settings you can change
what shows up here and where so if i go
into the settings and i go scroll down
to my notification drawer you can
actually choose what stuff shows up in
which tile i have wi-fi on location on
the top two and those are the two larger
ones up there so that means these are
things you can't change if you don't
have cyanogenmod or another custom rom
of course you still keep all the fancy
animations of swiping down and pulling
down your notifications that android l
has introduced so all the material
design stuff and all of the simplicity
and the beauty of android l is still
here of course you just get the
additions depending on what you like
there's another little one that i like
up at the top in the notification bar
here you can change the way it looks and
a lot of people you'll see in this
status bar have a circular battery
indicator that's just by changing the
battery style to a circle and now you
have it's a half circle for having half
battery i actually changed it back to
the portrait icon just to keep the looks
of stock android i guess i'm boring like
that i also don't really use any themes
although you can be much more creative
than me in changing the looks of your
cyanogenmod device because there are a
bunch of themes available in their own
store and in the google play store too
also you'll notice the performance is
pretty snappy in fact i've noticed a lot
of things moving around faster than they
did on my nexus 6. also little things
like the little weather information up
here about how cold it is and being able
to tap it and getting a little daily
forecast from yahoo weather stuff like
that really neat there's a file manager
built into cyanogenmod and that's again
something you get from root access that
you don't get in regular stock android
also stuff like gestures from when your
screen is off things you'll remember
from saanich and mod 11s so for example
when your screen is off you can draw a
circle to activate the camera and
sometimes i found that this would
activate in my pocket so i didn't use it
very often but if you're one of those
people that opens the camera all the
time or needs to very quickly toggle the
flashlight you can just draw on the
screen while the this display is off and
immediately get stuff to turn on so
that's awesome and pretty useful so yeah
that's basically it that's what i've
found so far to be really interesting
about cyanogenmod 12 on this one plus
one and that's kind of the beauty of
android is if you get impatient with
something or if you really want to
change something about the user
interface or the feature set you have
you can just go out and do it so that's
pretty awesome that we've been able to
do that so far i've also flashed the
franco kernel and apparently it's
supposed to get me amazing battery life
this is only the second day i've been
using it full time and it's been pretty
good so far but i'll leave some updates
on twitter if you guys want to follow
along about my usage with that it's been
a while since i used a custom kernel but
either way that's been it uh thank you
for watching and if you are down to try
this kind of stuff on your oneplus one
it's actually becoming a little bit more
easy to buy apparently every
tuesday at a certain time you can buy
this phone without an invite
it's kind of still weird but you can
also still wait for phones like the htc
one m9 and the galaxy s6 that are coming
up right around the corner either way
you're called thank you for watching
this video and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace